it was supposed to be a speech for new
graduates of his paramilitary rapid
support forces but on tuesday the deputy
head of sudan's sovereignty council once
again turned his attention to the
civilians in the transitional government
a week after an attempted coup tension
between the military and civilian sides
of the administration remains at an
all-time high
they blame us we are part of the
partnership politics are based on things
i don't like but i've learned my lessons
i'm a military man the council was
created to have all the decisions
and after that they said it was a
council for consultation only but if
you're a council for consultation you
can't oblige people to apply and
implement your decisions
sudan's transitional government came to
power months after former president
ahmad bashir was overthrown in april
2019 the power sharing administration
was intended to lead the country into a
democratic system by early 2024
but tensions between the ruling
political coalition that forms the
civilian side and the military
have raised concerns about the future of
the partnership for months political
parties have demanded reforms in the
military they say like other
institutions the army contains members
loyal to bashir's regime and needs to be
restructured
that angered the military and the coup
attempt has further fueled calls for its
reform
we are committed to evaluating this
transitional period we are capable of
amending it but it's only us who will
amend it because we are the ones
representing you no other person can
change this equation
a war of words between the two sides has
been followed by the army with drawing
protection from the committee formed to
dismantle the former ruling party and
fight corruption
that led to protests in the capital
khartoum in show of support for the
civilian leadership the sudanese
professionals association which
spare-headed anti-government protests
that led to the overthrow of president
bashir called for an end to the power
sharing agreement the un has urged both
sides to preserve the partnership
[Music]
this partnership model is a unique
approach which can lead sudan to a
complete democratic transition of
civilian rule and peace
i urge all sides to tone down on the
media rhetoric and to focus on dialogue
and cooperation
political differences are natural but
there must be cooperation for the sake
of the country
while tension between the two sides
remains those who let protests against
the former government have called for
more demonstrations against the military
they say that despite any shortcomings
among political parties they still want
to ensure that civilians have the upper
hand in running the country and not the
military hebrew morgan al-jazeera
hartung